Let's conclude our look at mental
disorders by examining autism and
schizophrenia, which are two of the
most troubling of the mental disorders.
We're going to look at some evidence
that comes from genetic copy number
variants.
Then we'll examine the CRESPI
Badcock hypothesis, which, uh,
is generated by cases of rare mutations
that cause mental disorders but which
they generalized.
Then we'll look at a Meta
analysis of copy number variation,
and at size, at birth as a marker of
risk for autism and schizophrenia.
The insight that led to the Crespi
Badcock hypothesis came from David Hague's
comments on the contrast between
Angelman and Prader Willi Syndrome.
These are generated by deletions
and duplications of genes. In fact,
these are generated by deletions that
produced copy number variation deletions
of genes that are imprinted differently
in mother or father produced behavioral
syndromes that contain clues
to broader mental disorders.
So Angela and and prod or willy are
deletions of genes that are imprinted
differently in mother or father.
When the maternally inherited copy of
a region of chromosome 15 is deleted,
allowing the paternally inherited coffee
to be expressed unimpeded by maternal
influence.
The result has angelman syndrome,
angelman babies demand
suckling crying frequently.
They're hyperactive,
they sleep very little,
they tend to be very happy and they
have a high risk 40 to 80% of autism.
So this high risk of autism is associated
with over expression of paternal
interest unimpeded by maternal genes.
When the paternally inherited copy
of the same region is deleted,
allowing the maternally inherited
genes to be expressed unimpeded.
The result is Prader Willi Syndrome,
Prader Willi infant suckle poorly cry
weekly are inactive and sleepy and have
high risk 30 to 70% of psychosis,
which includes schizophrenia.
So when maternal interest is overexpressed
unimpeded by paternal resistance,
the result is an infant that doesn't ask
for very much parental investment and
is at high risk of psychosis.
Yeah,
so similar patterns of deletion and two
other regions produce similar contrasts
in autism versus psychosis.
Yeah.
This led to the crispy Badcock hypothesis.
It sees a the a spectrum
ranging from hyper mentalism,
which is psychosis through a
normal area to Hypo mentalism,
which they define as autism.
If there is maternal bias,
then with small deviations
in this direction,
you have less demanding offspring and
lower birth weight and larger deviations
lead to psychotic type behavior deviations
in the autistic direction or caused
by paternal bias in gene expression.
Smaller deviations lead to more demanding
offspring, higher birth weights,
longer gestation times, larger deviations
lead to autistic type behavior.
This explanation is seen as being
layered onto the effects of non imprinted
genes and onto environmental effects.
So maternally biased imprints are seen
as part of a multi causal explanation of
psychosis and paternal imprints are seen
as part of a multi causal explanation
of autism.
Okay,
so in this view,
autism and psychosis are seen as
opposite extremes in the social brain.
If the human social brain is
overdeveloped, it leads to schizophrenia,
bipolar syndrome and depression that's
associated with auditory hallucinations,
Megalomania, paranoia, delusion,
major depression or elation
thought disorders. And meniam
under development leading to autism
can lead to people who cannot speak,
who have a reduced sense of self,
no mentalistic skill.
That means very little
ability to understand what's
going on in other people's
heads. Very basic
emotions, mechanical logic.
And no goal pursuit.
So this syndrome is seen as
varying along a spectrum.
There was some support for this,
uh,
that comes from a Meta analysis
of copy number variation.
So this was carried out by
Crespi and his colleagues.
One Meta analysis of 18 papers found
a significant and striking contrast of
deletions and duplications
in Chromosomal region.
One Q 21.1 deletions raise the risk of
schizophrenia and duplications raise the
risk of autism.
So this is a highly significant contrast
in risks as mental disease where you
have copy number variation in
the same region of a chromosome.
They did seven such analyses for
including that one we just saw revealed
diametrically opposed reciprocal risk
that supports the idea that autism and
schizophrenia are in some sense opposite
ends of a single dimensional spectrum.
However,
in two are in two of these four deletions,
raise the risk of
schizophrenia and duplications,
raise the risk of autism in
two of those four deletions,
the risk of autism duplication's
raise the risk of schizophrenia.
So we're getting this diametrically
opposed effect. However,
in the other three regions,
uh, there was no such contrast.
So coffee number variation contributes
to risks of autism and schizophrenia,
but that's not the whole story for
each of those. Also has other causes.
When a mother's interests
are overexpressed,
infants tend to be born smaller and
earlier when the father's interests are
overexpressed,
infants are born larger and later
we can contrast Angelman, which leads
to paternal bias with prodder Willie,
which leads to maternal
bias and Beckwith Wiedemann,
which leads to paternal bias with Silver
Russell, which leads to maternal bias
and analysis of 1.7 5 million births
in Denmark between 1977 and 2009 showed
that infants with these
syndromes of maternal bias,
we're heavier at birth and had longer
gestation periods than infants with
syndromes of maternal bias.
If the imbalance input
parental transcripts that
influence size of birth was
expressed in the brain,
we would expect size at birth to be
associated with risk of mental disorder.
Okay.
This in fact is the risk of mental
disorder in that population in Denmark,
these are 1.7 5 million people.
The bars here in the histograms are the
numbers of births and you'll notice that
they're going up to a factor of this
would be a 100,000 so this is about a
hundred thousand births here
and this is relative risk.
So you can see that the relative risk
of psychosis is much higher for infants
that are small and much smaller.
For infants that are born in large,
the relative risk of autism is very
high for infants that are born large,
it drops and then it rises again in very,
very small infants. So there's needs to
be something about very small brains,
which is resetting the
circuitry, uh, and for,
for both kinds of disease.
So to summarize
in,
in this lecture,
we've looked at the connection between
genomic conflict in mental disorders and
it's made by inferring the imbalance
of genetic transcripts that influence
behavior is usually normal and healthy.
Autism and schizophrenia are
not thought to be selected,
but they are to be thought
to be pathological byproducts
of the disruption of an
equilibrium that usually
results in normal children.
This interpretation is supported both by
the contrast of rare monogenic diseases.
Such as proud or willy and angelman in
which either the maternal or the paternal
is deleted.
And this also was supported by the
Association of birth weights with disease
risk in an entire country.
The portion of variation in risk
of autism and schizophrenia,
that's accounted for by
this sort of explanation.
Genomic conflict is probably not more
than 2020 5% so this is interesting and
it's only a part of the story.